la situación está grave desde desde
siempre desde el comienzo de este
conflicto desde la creación del estado
de Israel pero se está agravando cada
día más y con este gobierno como usted
bien lo ha dicho Ultra nacionalista
Ultra otra ortodoxo por las ecuación se
va a agradar más porque fue muy claro en
sus declaraciones en el tuit que él
publicó donde dijo y acá pues cito que
el pueblo judío tiene el derecho
exclusivo y en cuestionable a todas las
áreas de la tierra de Israel
promocionaré y desarrollaré colonias en
todas partes de la tierra de Israel
refiriéndose hacia incluso la llama como
judea y samaria se rehúsa a llamarla
como territorio palestino ocupado o
territorio o son ocupadas eso demuestra
de que Israel pues está entrando a una
nueva etapa de fascismo de más aparcaid
en contra de la población Palestina en
los territorios ocupados señor embajador
y precisamente también hay preocupación
entre gran parte de la población por la
tendencia racista y homófoba de algunos
de los nuevos socios de extrema derecha
de Benjamín taniao que pueden esperar
estas minorías de este nuevo gobierno
Pues la verdad es que esto estamos
viendo
un gobierno que va a ser un gobierno que
se va a expandir la construcción de
asentamientos va a formalizar lo que es
el apartado en Israel en contra de la
población Palestina sobre todo La
minoría Palestina también en el centro
del estado de Israel y demás minorías y
faltaría no faltaría decir que en contra
de la población Palestina en territorio
palestino ocupado Cuando tenemos a este
en este gobierno ministros que van a a
manejar lo que es las operaciones dentro
de lo que es el territorio palestino
ocupado como son los asentamientos
Entonces estamos
aproximando a una anexión formal de lo
que es el territorio palestino ocupado
esto manda un mensaje para la comunidad
internacional
que tiene que reaccionar Israel no puede
seguir disfrutando de esa impunidad
eterna que le da